in this lesson we're going to talk about
simplifying radicals so this is an
important concept to understand so let's
go through some examples and we'll have
you do some on your own so first of all
I just want to show you how to work with
radicals so if you're multiplying a
number times the number that's easy
right you just get a number so 3 times 4
that's 12 if you're multiplying a square
root times the square root what you do
is you multiply what's underneath the
square roots and you get another square
root so square root of 15 if you
multiply a number times the radical
right there side by side like that you
just keep them side by side so it's just
going to be a number radical so 2 times
square root of two you just put it right
next to each other this represents 2
times square root of two and then the
last example here is if you're
multiplying a number radical times the
number radical you're multiplying the
numbers together so 3 times 4 is 12
you're multiplying the square roots
together seven times two gives you the
square root of 14 so it's kind of like
multiplying like terms right okay now
let's talk about simplifying a square
root so feel like you have a square root
of 48 there's a couple different ways to
do this you can either try to divide out
a perfect square for example like 48 is
like 16 times 3 and the reason i divide
out 16 equals at the perfect square
square root of sixteen is four so you
get 4 root 3 sometimes it's not so
obvious you know what these perfect
squares are that you can divide out so
another technique I like to show is you
can do a prime factorization for you
just go ahead and break down that number
into its prime factors okay like so and
then what you're doing is you're looking
for if you're taking the square root
you're looking for two of the same
number so here there's a pair that's
like four square root of four is two
there's two twos so that's like four
squared of four is two and we have a
three left over so you can see we're
getting 2 times 2 which is four square
root of three okay so same result and
then this example here we don't want to
have a radical in the denominator that's
considered improper see what you want to
do is you want to rationalize and way
you do that is you x square root of 2
over square root of two because square
root of two times square root of two
thats square root of four which is two
and that's getting rid of the radical in
the denominator but whatever you do the
desire you want to do to the numerator
as well so then here we're multiplying a
number times a radical we just get a
number around
we've got it now there's one other
scenario and that's it if you have
something like this where it's a
binomial okay you have two terms in the
denominator and you still have that
radical you want to get rid of that
radical what you're going to do is
you're going to multiply by the
conjugate and what the conjugate is it's
the same quantity you have here you're
just changing that sign in between the
two values okay so this was + this would
be minus you don't want to change this
from 1 to negative 1 just to sign in
between the two terms okay so that what
you want to do is you just want to
multiply this out so let me see if I can
do that for you here so 3 times 1 and 3
times root 2 so x 3 plus 3 root 2 and in
the denominator we're going to do is I'm
gonna do the foil or you can distribute
twice so 1 times 1 is 1 1 times root 2
is positive root 2 negative root 2 times
1 is negative root 2 and then negative
root 2 times positive 2 is negative
square root of four but that's actually
going to be square root of 4 is 2 so
that's going to be negative to the root
2 and a route to cancel one minus two is
negative one so we get 3 plus 3 root to
all over negative 1 but you could divide
both these by negative 1 and just make
it negative 3 minus 3 root 2 okay so
that's just a general overview of how to
work with radicals let's do an example
here so you can do this on your own
pause the video it says even if y equals
3 square root of three and five times y
equals the square root of three X what
is the value of x right so go ahead and
pause the video see if you can do that
in your own and now we'll go through it
together so what I would do is this y
equals 3 root 3 I would put that in
place the wire right there so it's just
a substitution right so we have 5 times
3 square root of 3 equals the square
root of 3x now remember when you
multiply number times number right so 5
times 3 is 15 square root of 3 or I'm
not multiplying the five times the
square root of three just the two
integers together right okay Matty
equals the square root of three X our
goal is to get X by itself so what's the
opposite of taking the square root logs
to square both sides I'm going to square
both sides like this the square the
square root cancel you get 3x here 15
root 3-squared remember that's really
like 15 root 3 times another 15 root 3
right because you're squaring it you
have two of them 15 x 15 is 225 square
root 3 times square root of 3 is square
root of nine but the square root of nine
is three and that equals 3x i can
multiply these together but what I
notice here is I could divide both sides
by 3 because I'm just trying to solve
for 1x the three is canceled and I can
see that x equals 2 25 now if you want
to check your answer you know you can
put 225 back in over here and I Lentz
and substitute over here and make sure
the left side in the right side equal
each other but that's probably how I
would approach this problem if you need
to review radicals go ahead and look at
these examples here again I'll see you
in the next lesson